so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
good morning good morning happy
happy hump day
noon eastern 11 central you know what
time that is it is time for let's talk
johnny michael's podcast we have a great
show for you today
stay in your seats for all two hours
every single last one of those minutes
for those two hours we have we have a
great show uh gabe's gonna be joining us
here soon we're also gonna be joined
today
by jojo from jurors we have that
interview ready to go we're gonna play
trivia we play trivia with joe um we
talked about um becky sue everyone loves
joe's becky sue's videos um so we talk
becky sue we also talk about social
media in general and like what it means
um and how
you know it matters it matters what you
put on social media and it can change
things
so we talk about that as well in the
interview so i'm very excited to play
that um
because we talked to jojo
you know jojo is one of our favorite
here on the [ __ ] list roundup when we're
going through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends which we are gonna get to
pretty darn quick because uh we talked
to joe for quite some time and we played
trivia so i want to make sure all that
gets into the two hours
very exciting so we'll go through the
tweet tweets and trendy trends here in
just a second but again every single
weekday
every single weekday we have the [ __ ]
list roundup we have the interviews
yesterday we had eric trump on for the
interview did you guys see this you guys
see yesterday eric trump was on
i cut i cut the video out and
we put uh we put the video up on the use
the use of tubes the tubes of you so you
can go watch that interview and we cut a
clip uh oh i say we gabe cut a clip
sorry actually speaking of speaking of
gabe and we got gabe here gabe how are
you this morning oh i am good hey that
mike is working this morning that might
oh oh my
yeah
yeah what what i can't we can't hear you
again yeah here here he goes with the
mic here he goes yeah yeah yeah uh
yesterday yesterday eric trump joined us
on the show
what did you think what did you think
about
eric did you see that did you see the
interview that we had i did i i did i
did see the interview when i was cutting
it together
uh man that
that kid is
he's really losing it man he's also not
too bright not too bright
well i don't i don't think i don't think
that's um
um i don't know maybe it runs in the
family i'm not exactly sure all i know
is that he seems to be just breaking at
the seams
very emotional this was like an oprah
interview kind of thing he just like let
it all out the hair though the hair is
was
yeah i don't know what's going on with
his hair but
you know he loves to slick it back so
right right well you know i mean i guess
i guess a guy would
you know if he if he had hair like that
right
so so
you know all kidding aside of course um
it was you it was you as as eric trump
you got to ruin the surprise yeah i know
i know i know i know but yes yes it was
it was it was gabe for all those
wondering um yeah we you didn't trick
anybody this time as eric trump as you
did with pastor brian there was a lot of
people that actually thought yeah you
were pastor brian
yeah that was
i don't i don't know why that was like
i don't know
i think it was the beard it was the
beard even people who know you really
well were like you had me like i had
because i think you posted did you post
a clip on twitter of that that was like
a small clip i think yeah yeah i posted
a uh two sections where right pastor
brian was talking about
basically when he realized that women
had the right to vote yeah yeah that's
right that's right yeah and then there
was another one where he just basically
revealed himself to say he was he it
made him feel uncomfortable and he was
jealous and envious that people could be
who they were and he couldn't
right right well and and that i think is
where people got confused that it was
you
right like because the beard it was very
quick and it was like i don't know it's
like a minute 30 but yeah a lot of
people were like oh my god 30 seconds in
is when i realized or a minute in is
when i realized yeah people were like i
hate this guy and i was like yeah me
this guy sucks yeah yeah this guy
[ __ ] he's terrible yesterday so just
so the audience knows like when you
sometimes when you do the costumes i
have no idea i have no yeah yeah yeah no
clue now yesterday i did know eric trump
was coming but that is all i knew so i
knew what time and who was going to be
here so what i did was make sure that i
was doing the eric trump sean hannity
yeah clip right at about the time
right that eric trump was gonna show up
yeah it's uh i was
i was
i was doing i was like running to
errands and then you were like you're
gonna come on the show this morning and
i was like yeah but i'm coming on as a
character i'm gonna be eric trump right
right right right and i've been meaning
to try out this wig because here's the
thing what i can't i don't have blonde
hair i've got brown you bought the wig
just to be eric
not for this show oh okay to be eric
like oh right right right right he's
gonna do something dumb and i need to
play him right but i mean but i mean
specifically this is the eric wig yeah
this is the
trump wig okay uh this is the closest
thing i could find to blonde-ish hair
that was like slicked back which not
anyone really makes unless you're
willing to like throw down some cash for
a wig and i don't have enough respect
for these dumb [ __ ] to actually spend
the money on them right so i'm gonna buy
a wig that's close enough and this
happens to be like i think a mr
incredibles wig for like okay it's it's
real tight like it is tight on my head
well you can tell because like yeah you
know the the oh the hair on the side i
wish the hair would come down and i
tried to cover it up a little bit but i
was like ah [ __ ] it whatever
so yeah it definitely was one of those
moments of uh i'm gonna buy this wig for
this character i'll probably have
another one but also
uh
it's the closest thing i could find that
could be for eric because if i sleep my
her back and i comb it or whatever then
people automatically assume i'm don
junior right and when i did that because
you've done you've done eric before with
that
and right and also don junior's the same
because they have the same haircut
that's just different exactly so i
thought hey i'll make a video of eric
trump doing his deposition
with
uh
with you know uh leticia james and
um people were people assumed that i was
don jr even though i said at the
beginning right and it said on there
eric yeah right yeah exactly but people
don't read it they just look at the
videos right right understand the
confusion people like oh he needs more
coke or whatever and i'm like no this is
not this is why
it's the dummy right exactly i mean
they're both dumb but at the same time
if i
didn't then i could assume like
i get the confusion i know where people
were coming from but also it's like i
wrote it so
it said trump so so the the the best
there was a lot of good parts in the um
oh yeah because i went back and watched
the whole yeah it was 40 minutes 40
minutes of improv it was just straight
like ask the question i was listening
you know i had veteran yoda being like
say put the lotion on the skin
it was like all right i got to find a
way to do it well then then the chafing
nipples and then the best part is and if
you go if you go to youtube if you guys
when you're done with the show here go
to youtube because i took the clip the
twitter clip and i post on youtube and
and the the the thumbnail is you going
like this open up your eyes
look up look up look up i'm a real
hollywood director i'm like a really hot
i'm like a real hollywood director i'm
like a real one
okay well well there's a lot of topics
to get to because we got the interview
with jojo from jers um which i'm very
excited about we had a great time um
hanging out with her playing trivia
talking about social media talking about
her characters becky sue possible new
characters that are coming so we had a
lot of fun talking about that kind of
stuff joe is
suit not not just super cool on twitter
she's super cool in real life um so
you're going to want to watch this
interview you're going to want to stick
around
uh in in the the second half of this
hour and the second hour to catch that
but i want to do the [ __ ] list roundup
because there's a lot of topics to get
to i mean we've got the trump white
house logs we got this true social stuff
going on and some other things so let's
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome to the [ __ ] list roundup
where we round up all the tweety tweets
and the journey trends of the day we're
gonna have gabe surfing with us today
that's gonna be
that's going to be fun the whole time
the whole time surf's up um so so let's
let's get right into it the first thing
i want to start off with is have you
heard of this ram ranch thing oh dude
it's so great i've been sitting in on
these uh these twitter spaces they're
[ __ ] hilarious so so i haven't gone
into the twitter spaces the video that i
found is the uh
the windsor zello chat what the hell is
that i don't know is that some kind of
weird like um
like radio things yeah it's uh what was
it it's a messenger chat i believe uh
big well see like so i joined the
i joined the
twitter uh spaces one the other the last
couple days
and at first when you jump into these
they sound like a goddamn parody like
they're insane but but it's but the
people that are talking in these things
are [ __ ] real right right yeah why i
mean i mean i mean the people who are in
uh are trying to organize for canada
right right i mean these people are on
there they're like you know they're i
like i requested to talk several times
and i wasn't able to be picked i saw
some people go in there they were like
they were like and they would play a
song or like i i heard them get rick
roll they were doing stuff they're like
hey so yeah when we get a ranch uh when
we like get the property and overthrow
the government you know we'll get this
ranch and someone's like and then we'll
have a lot of ramps to ram ranch
so like so like these people like they
know this is happening so how are they
how are they like
when i was when i was in the twitter
spaces ones they were uh
they were you know letting people talk
and then if they had any
like
any kind of hint that this person was
about to troll them
you know they would jump them off and so
like i had people know this woman was
like yeah so i'm i just want everyone to
stop yelling because it's scaring up my
dog and uh there are kids on the line
right now
somebody came in and impersonated a kid
that was really weird
uh they got kicked out uh this one this
another person came in as a kid and
they're like i can't find my mom you
know i was like oh my god this is crazy
but these people are like non-stop
harassing them hilariously so
but they're doing it
as if they're like other truckers
trying to overthrow the government
anytime they mentioned over to the
government they would be like nope
that's a cop toss them that's a cop toss
so they were like
people were you know as admins they were
moderating and throwing people out so
well so that's that's this video that
the other thor has posted here this is
on um
the windsor zello chat whatever that app
is um i i i didn't actually go see what
it was i'm assuming it's like a
clubhouse type thing where you're or
like a twitter spaces type thing um this
was this was at 7pm but this was a
several days ago this moment is one of
the greatest in monarch
modern counter protest history so this
video here let's um let's zoom out here
this video
is the chat it's like the screenshot of
the chat the capture of it but listen
cause the ram ranch is a song it's a
it's a [ __ ] song did you know that
uh i i got hints of that because they
kept playing music i didn't know what it
was yeah so so listen listen to this
video because they they know they're
being infiltrated and then listen to the
song it's hard to hear but listen
closely um so
uh
it's come to my attention that this
group has been infiltrated um
they set out to have
one
goal in mind and
the goal kind of worked
worked its way in the inner circle um
and
it actually worked didn't actually think
it was going to work it was kind of a
little too easy
if i'm being quite honest
18 naked cowboys
[Laughter]
so so here's the thing so i'm not sure
exactly what ram wrench is someone
actually i think it was um uh midas man
he posted because i i retweeted this and
he posted in the thread that ram ranch
resistance this song is on spotify i
believe um if you want to go you know if
you want to go
make sure to to patron these resistors
that are going inside these chats and
dumping these this song inside these
jets and doing this uh ram resistance
which i think actually i think actually
what we should do is change the name of
this thing from
from the trucker convoy to the ram ranch
resistance like that should be the thing
yeah yeah totally
resistance ram ranchers it's a ram ranch
resistance is what it is to resist
fascism and i think it's a beautiful a
beautiful thing that this that this song
talks about
gay guys sucking each other right that's
that's what it sounds yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and and that that this is and
they're freaking out in these in these
chats and stuff that this is happening
it is
phenomenal phenomenal that these people
are [ __ ] freaking out um so see but
you're saying they're having twitter
spaces is what you're saying yeah so uh
so rachel uh
she she tagged me in in one of them and
was like
you got to get in on this and i was like
what the hell is this so i joined and
i'm you know it got hundreds of oh
rachel bitcoffer yeah yeah yeah oh okay
okay he tagged me so i went into one the
other day and then i was listening and i
was like i can't tell this is parody or
not
is this [ __ ] real well some of it is
some of it isn't right right right so so
they were talking and it was like yeah
there were troubles up here going
probably resistance so we got to figure
out how we set up our own bank and all
this stuff and i was like is that the
real thing is that that was yeah that
was the real one and had a ton of people
listening and we're like what the [ __ ]
going on so then
uh
i requested to talk because i was like i
want to say something you know i want to
like see if i control these guys was i
was dude i was on hold for a request for
an hour and i listened to these guys
just just just to try to say something
to try to say something so i was like oh
man i got to get a hold of this early on
because they're using the hashtag
freedomconvoy2022 which which the freed
that hashtag is ram ranch resistance is
what it is what it is now right yeah
yeah yeah that's what it should be right
so uh yeah i was in there and i was
listening to some and people tried to
troll and do all this stuff because i
was like
i was like either these people are super
committed to the bit and they're out
here for hours doing that
like i don't know
like we were committed to eric trump
yeah right exactly
but at the same time
uh yeah it was one of those things i was
like this is so bizarre like this is
it's it's almost sounds like a parody
and then they were saying stuff and i
was like no this isn't a parody these
are real people
having a conversation
well so it's it's really weird that like
they can be duped so easily into
thinking that they're the freedom
fighters and there's a couple other
videos in that thread if you go to it
and you just go to my timeline and
there's several in there that they are
starting to realize like oh we're the
bad guys in this situation like we're
not the good guys we're the bad guys
like they're starting people are
starting to come around to oh we're
being duped in into spreading fascism
and an anti-democracy message because
they think that it's an anti-vaccine
message and it's not what they're doing
is trying to topple and really so doubt
in democracy right like that's the whole
objective the objective may not to be
insurrect the democracy or tear it down
but the object of it is to question
whether democracy works or not which
brings me to this next thing speaking of
parody democracy
russia canada like all in one in this
one [ __ ] video
now i'm gonna let me read the tweet look
at all these monitors this is this is
crazy [ __ ] man um amazing in a message
to vladimir putin q anon queen of canada
quote unquote this is the q and on queen
of canada um rejects ukraine's
application to join nato
right and officially welcomes russia to
the nato allies uh alliance this is
this is [ __ ] i this is real
this is a real lady she's apparently
some kind of q anon leader in canada
she's welcoming um um
russia into nato
it's it's it's really [ __ ] just listen
to this it's not very long
my fellow canadians i address you today
as your queen
commander in chief and head of governor
yep
this message is for president
vladimir putin of russia
i am rejecting
ukraine's
application to join nato
and
officially welcoming russia
to
nato alliance
god bless
and peace and prosperity
on earth
insanity
insanity
this this person i don't know she had
flags made she made flags right well
look at this [ __ ] she's got flags she's
got like like
god loves you i mean it of course you
know it's a cult it's a [ __ ] cult
like you people and and like and i don't
know if you could like
get this in front of these people that
are at this ram ranch that the ram ranch
resistance is trying to you know take
these this this [ __ ] fascism down but
and and show these people like look this
is what you're participating in this is
the kind of crazy that you people are
getting right up in front of like you
are right there with this lady with your
craziness like this is this is getting
out of [ __ ] control so this person
is for and and man
you can't make this [ __ ] up like
literally how would you parody this i
mean how would you go about it i would
just reshare this video like there's no
like
i don't know
because it's so
it's so bad [ __ ] crazy
to have someone
who is
self-appointed as the queen of canada
and then say oh we reject ukraine's
application and we accept russia's
application
and
there i just
it's as if the queen of canada even if
she was the queen of gamma right like
let's let's back up a second right yeah
like even if she actually was the queen
of canada right
what the [ __ ] would she why would the
queen of canada be able to just
unilaterally
reject ukraine's nato application and
accept vladimir putin's i don't
understand
how that is even but but what gets to
the heart of this really and what i
think is so dangerous to our democracy
and and and you know i said this
yesterday these people they don't care
about messaging they don't really care
about what is real and what's not what
they care about is is tearing down
democracies and sowing doubt and that's
what this is and here's where all this
stuff meets if you're still wondering if
q anon is propagated by russia
i would give you this as evidence like
this is clear evidence that not only
that q anon is russian propaganda but
the the ram the ram ranch
that the ram ranch resistance is
fighting
is rush russian propaganda i believe
that all the q anon the big lie in this
country is russian propaganda it's all
being clearly funded by the same actor
the right-wing actors all around the
world some of the stuff in australia is
is russian propaganda
and it's all to sow doubt on democracy
right yeah it's not it's not actual aim
to
necessarily have a fascist state here or
overthrow this government over to that
it's just a little by little eat away at
the idea that democracy is the best way
of social society and government right
right yeah and i think the thing too is
you know this is something that's not
new right like how do you
weaken your enemy or weaken those who
are uh foreign to you right like it's
not gonna be an overnight thing because
if it was an overnight thing then
somebody if not all the people would say
hey this is really [ __ ] up we can't do
this right
however
if you were to let's say get certain
uh
agents you know uh people who were
american and then you were able to flip
them you know
for whatever incentive or
blackmail if it were uh to make certain
decisions and and do certain policies
and enact certain things and here and
there and so like over time
the erosion of democracy through
uh an in from an internal enemy
is the way that you do it it's not it's
just little by little by little exactly
and it's and it's not invading right
right it's it's it's it's a deep pro
it's a deep roguing our reprogramming
from within right because they're really
deprogramming a population that
democracy may not be the best option
right right and we have we see this on
on on on the left and the right right
but the right is way more dangerous
because the right uses violence
they want to use death and just kill
their enemies the left is a little
different when you have this extreme
extremism towards totalitarianism right
like like
we we see this a little bit in in our
body politic um on the left with some of
the bernie sanders supporters who were
like bernie bust back in 2016. like that
that kind of errors on the side of
totalitarianism authoritarianism like
one person can fix it and if we can't
get that then we don't want anything the
same now a huge extreme and a huge huge
expansion of this idea through fox news
and the right-wing media because fascism
is a hell of a lot better vehicle to
sell totalitarianism than than is
communism or left-wing but um
in manga and this this trumpism [ __ ] um
and it's bleeding throughout the world
but here's here's what i believe here's
what i believe this is all an attempt
for vladimir putin to do exactly what
you're saying chip away at democracy
little by little but infiltrate
infiltrate the government so that he has
a way
he has a way of making sure he's still
in power because we've seen the ukraine
thing this morning and we're gonna get
to the interview here soon but i want to
go through the ukraine thing really
quick um i don't have a a lot of
articles to show you but i did see this
morning that it appears that russian
russian soldiers are moving around it
seems like they're pulling back but
putin's not saying they're pulling back
they're moving to different locations
well today was the today was the
anticipated day because correct uh
because we saw the president yesterday
with this right yeah and he gave a
warning a couple days ago as well to
saying like you know we anticipate the
16th to be the day in which you know
an invasion or an action against us is
taken
um
so i don't know i will say okay so
quickly last time the last point which
was like you know this slow erosion of
democracy from within the thing if
anyone out there or yourself has has
watched this before the planet earth uh
with sigourney weaver where she narrates
the parasite with the ant right right
anyone's seen that but there's this
basically how it works is a parasite
will invade a colony it'll it'll take
hold of of one ant right
and uh
from within it'll grow and drive that
ant crazy now if no one figures out
what's going on
then it it it just corrupts the whole
colony and they all get infected and
they all die however
there they can sense if an ant is off
right like it's going against the way
it's it's kind of off the you know the
beaten path and why not um
they're not adhering to the norms right
exactly right there's there's a mindset
right we're grouped by we're going to do
this together we're to accomplish a
greater good for the queen
right but what ends up happening is if
they don't then it crumbles in and fails
now there will be a few soldier ants
that will can detect this and say great
we are in charge of taking this [ __ ]
and
taking them miles away from the colony
so that they can't come back because
what's going to end up happening is this
thing gets disoriented it doesn't know
what's going on and if it affects
everyone it's done so what they end up
doing is taking it far away so that the
parasite could then
basically bust out of the ant like an
alien because it's been infecting and
driving it crazy
that's what's happening here and that's
i think that is the closest kind of
comparison to what's happening within
the country is like if we as
people who are pro-democracy do not
remove
this
this this parasite from the us then
what's gonna happen is
what we've seen happening it is slowly
eroding the minds and the democracy that
we have in this country so if we don't
do anything we're [ __ ] and so that's
that's our role right now that i see us
as is the people who are going to take
this [ __ ] parasite
you know filled ant
miles away so it doesn't affect the rest
of the us right
us pro-democracy people have to do our
part to uh get rid of the parasite as
you're saying which which i believe is
fascism but more more than anything just
in in in the way of fascism in this
country it really is anti-democracy
right like like they don't
fascism is just the easy vehicle right
that these that these anti-democracy
people are using that's the easy vehicle
to get people there and speaking of that
um because i want to go real quick here
soon to the trump white house vlogs also
that that's in the news but i also want
to talk about this true social before we
do the uh oh yeah yeah the interview
with the jojo from jurors because i
think that that all plays into this but
when you talk about when you talk about
uh propaganda and the right wing and
fascism so we've seen durham release um
his court document which is all [ __ ]
with hillary clinton and the emails um
and i think i think this is a setup and
here's what i think this the right wing
setup is they want john durham to do
this and they want it to appear that the
department of justice is not prosecuting
hillary clinton right right so they want
the department of justice and merit
garland to look like they're not
prosecuting a very high
you know a very uh uh uh high up
official a a a former president or
almost president
um because they want that messaging and
the reason why they want that messaging
on their side is because that messaging
has already started to take hold on the
pro-democracy side right so the
pro-democracy side is keep saying over
and over and over again oh my god if we
don't do something today if merrick
garland doesn't act we need to get
merrick garland out we need to get
someone who will act right that language
has already worked its way into the the
pro-democracy language which is a
problem and the reason why it's a
problem with messaging is because the
right wing is about to appropriate that
language the
get rid of merrick garland the only way
to get rid of merrick garland
is to vote in republicans right so
they're going to change the message but
people out there that already have this
little bit in their brain that oh merit
the attorney general isn't isn't
prosecuting powerful people like trump
when they do the whole hillary clinton
thing right it's gonna start to erode at
pro-democracy so we and that's that
[ __ ] parasite little by little by
little that's why us as pro-democracy
people can't let ourselves
have
have the parasite and eat it too right
right like we can't we can't have both
you can't you can't just you can't make
sure to get rid of the parasite that's
going to destroy democracy but embrace
it when it helps you and what i mean by
helps you is helps your narrative that
oh merrick garland we need to get
someone who's going to prosecute trump
but you know so we have to be very
careful on how we're messaging this
stuff um because we do need to hold
merrick garland and department of
justice accountable we do need to do
that and and and here's here's some
reasons why let's go to um
let's see let's go back to
let's see i think true social is still
uh trending here
uh did it do
4.99 you can uh so
so this is this is funny so first thing
i want to do is the trump logs uh
apparently joe biden and the biden
administration are going to release the
logs uh the trump white house logs which
is pretty significant if i can find it
here
um it was just executive executive
privilege yeah well so so that is very
significant and i think the reason why
and of course it's not showing up the
reason why it's significant is because
it's going to show who was in that
[ __ ] who is in the white house when
they were in the white house and what
discussions and i think it's going to be
significant for the january 6th select
committee to tell that story to america
because i believe this is the real thing
that will happen
is that
prosecutions no prosecutions who's
prosecuted who's not prosecuted who goes
to prison who doesn't i believe that
when america
actually discovers the story that the
the current president of the united
states at the time during january 6
donald trump was trying to overthrow the
constitution like that was their goal
when they discover that and it clicks in
their brain that there was a coup
attempt
then what will happen is it will change
the it will change the narrative america
doesn't know this yet i i've said this
before i was talking to a good friend
the other day he's not dumb he doesn't
he doesn't not pay attention to the news
he pays attention to current issues he
had no idea that the trump white house
and the trump administration were
destroying documents no clue had no clue
that that top secret documents were down
at mar-a-lago that this reporting even
existed no [ __ ] clue this is not a
stupid person this is not a person that
doesn't pay attention to political
issues
but it is not in the national
conversation yet and that is a problem
speaking of the national conversation
and social media and how it works uh we
have truth social
so you were saying 499
um what what is it because here's here's
the story don jr
uh here we're back to don junior post
the screen joe baden post
post a screenshot on instagram of what
he says is former president trump's
first post on upcoming social media
platform true social which we wouldn't
know because you can't download it it
doesn't work correct
uh i believe you can download the app uh
however you can't do anything with it
and
the the reason that it's so
that this is so hilarious is because
they went on
to twitter
right to advertise an app that you
cannot get access to right but at the
same time for all these people who
complain and [ __ ] and moan about oh you
know what
twitter sucks we hate twitter don't be
on twitter
they just promoted an app that looks
identical
to twitter
do you think do you think their mate
twitter may sue trump or true social at
some point because i don't know exactly
how how the lights are yeah so i can
tell you i can tell you this much as a
designer who has worked on mobile apps
and websites um from the design aspect
you have no real grounds to sue anyone
because
you know everyone isn't you know
you're talking about the source code
that makes it look the way it looks is
that well that no no that that's
completely different if they were for
whatever reason had access to
uh
uh
uh the the actual code algorithms like
the way that it was developed and
programmed then sure that's a that's
that's an issue because they have
uh
that is proprietary
uh right
uh uh
that's that's right that's there yeah
it's their property yeah exactly that's
their ip however on the design side
there's little you could do on that
because
uh they look similar
but they're not the same so unless they
were stealing things that were verbatim
the same way or whatever no it looks
identical obviously for the purpose that
they want to bring people over because
it's something that looks the same
but there's little that they can do in
terms of the aesthetic or look and feel
of a website because if you don't do
that case like you look at all social
media everyone is like some version of
facebook and how like a feed looks and
how cards look and how a profile a round
profile photo and uh a cover photo like
they're all
they're all stealing from each other you
know as inspiration
but um there's little that you could do
for like oh this is an exact replica now
if that were the case you know right
well here's the problem that i see with
it well
there's a couple liam nissan here
alludes to one trump's new true social
is where free speech quote unquote costs
4.99 a week this is not a month a
[ __ ] week they're charging them by
the week and i think the reason why
they're charging by the week is like
well we'll get the first 12 weeks out of
them maybe 11 weeks we'll charge them by
the week because there's no way that
someone would like do a month you know
or whatever right i think that's why
they're doing but i also think the
reason this is is because one uh well
these people have already donated money
to this campaign or this like election
defense fund or whatever the [ __ ] it's
called but
4.99
per week right that's five bucks four
weeks that's 20 bucks 12 months 240
bucks a year right now i don't think
anyone's really gonna do this now
remember the company that's behind this
is trading is publicly traded but
there's that whole like
what yeah it's a pump and dump right
exactly what's going on it's being
investigated and on top of that
the other thing is i see people who are
like oh you know like [ __ ] uh
what's his face i just made fun of this
morning
um
nick adams right yeah right yeah because
he because he basically said it's gonna
make him rich right it's gonna make him
rich which is at the same time it's like
well you know what actually i think jeff
bezos and elon musk and bill gates have
something to say about that right right
right but you look at it and you say
like to do the math right like that's
240 a year per person
right now you you want to get into the
triple digits of billions of dollars
like there are not that many people
right the us has 330 350 million people
right like you're you're not gonna get
to levels that you want that would
assume everyone was going to join now
right which they're not right exactly
but what i think is happening here is
they're using this to [ __ ] bootstrap
this [ __ ] app right you don't have
the money right so they're going to
actually keep they're going to turn
right right so they're going to go in
the black or they're going to go in the
in the red real quick so they've got to
have cash exactly so if you get cash up
front
then that's that's my there's probably
little you can do in terms of getting
that money refunded so they're trying to
get people on the hook immediately to
sign up and i wouldn't be surprised if
they offer some sort of like annual fee
where it's like oh if you pay all of it
up front then give you like a 10
discount well so so so that leads me to
my next point because here's what i see
happening because we already see it with
don jr posting the
whatever it's called on true social on
twitter
here's here's the problem that it looks
so much like twitter and that they're
going to be saying that trump tweeted
they're going to say i tweeted on this
you you're really you're you're it's not
going to work it's not going to work
because you're tweeting
so here's the other reason why i think
the 499 is going to [ __ ] fail is
because why would you pay 4.99 to go to
a website and look at him tweet because
that's literally what you're doing
you're paying you're just going to see
him
when everyone is going to screenshot
the post that he post
and then put it over right on the free
trip
and i'm not saying that someone out
there should take the the post and make
it the way it looks and do fake posts
and post those i'm just saying i'm not
saying someone should i'd probably piss
off daniel dale for sure probably did
that so i'm gonna get a knock on my
front door from daniel daley he's gonna
be like excuse me
this is not actually real
and i'd be like
thank you daniel now come on the show
yeah i'm i want daniel on because i want
to i want to um i want to talk to him
about about the
you know you know that
yeah you know the the past and possibly
future right possibly future of what
could happen you know maybe we could
clue in um the handful of fact checkers
that you piss off on a weekly basis i
will say this some of the fact i mean
like i'm now on kind of a first name
basis with a few fact checkers that have
that have reached out to me and they're
like hey your post went viral can we get
a quote
and i'm like okay
you know what you know what's funny is
someone dm me like some kind of
screenshot did i think i sent it to you
they're like is this gabe is this gabe
i'm like a [ __ ] i don't know how the
[ __ ] am i supposed to know i
they act like i've got some kind of
insight like half the time half the time
it's tweeted before i even [ __ ] know
that
where it came from right so you know i
mean i mean i when i see the statements
i try to send them to you right so you
can see that yeah i know i haven't done
one in a few weeks well apparently the
the last one that happened with grandpa
poopypants over over this uh the mizar's
the accounting firm right [ __ ] he
went he's lost yeah
i mean it is uh you know makes sense you
would get pissed off too if the company
that you know is like hey we can't
account for the last 10 years of
whatever the documents he gave us like
that's the sign of like
them the accounting firm going oh [ __ ]
everyone's career as a cpa you know
lawyer
uh financial
kind of advisor
is now at stake because if we say yes to
this decade of of taxes or these
documents we're [ __ ] we're [ __ ] i
mean we're probably already [ __ ] but
we would just be less [ __ ] well and i
said this yesterday
when you're in the situation that myself
is in you got a choice and you got only
two choices you are either going to be
part of the prosecution or you're going
to be part of the defense yeah so they
chose they chose to be part of the
prosecution that is obvious here alan
weiserberg has chosen to be part of the
defense obviously the trump family and
the trump organization has decided to be
part of the defense but the accounting
firm who filed their [ __ ] financial
reports for for decades took the last
the last 10 or 12 or so and said they're
[ __ ] ridiculous this is not real
and they are going to be part of the
prosecution now and i think that's very
significant because remember this is the
same accounting firm that all the time
during the election
and uh after that when he was like oh
well i'm being audited i'm being audited
they're auditing me the irs is auditing
me these these fake these fake claims
that he said was like if you're being
audited you can't release the documents
right you can't release them because
they can change and because they're
being updated and this and this and that
right
and that is not true that
that that's just right he made that up
but remember you
made [ __ ] up come on right i know it's
crazy but remember
that all these claims he made when he
was running for president to say like oh
i can't show it because i'm under audit
i can't do it because they're reviewing
it i can't do it because that's the
accounting firm that up until this point
they were completely fine
with letting him make these claims they
weren't getting into that [ __ ] right
they weren't doing it because i don't
even know if it was public maybe it
might have been but i don't know well no
there's been people reporting on this
myself since 2018 and really um doing
some pressure but it wasn't like it
wasn't like mainstream like right about
it because
once it was brought up it was dismissed
of this like it's under audit right so
it was like we're going to keep billing
we're going to keep doing well that's
that's the big lie in the in the
mountain of life that's why he has so
many lies because
it's crazy it took this long
to
get them to finally say oh you know what
[ __ ] we are well but i think tis james
is the one who's got them here um
because of the civil lawsuit and i think
that's why it's so important to to
understand that there is a civil and a
criminal lawsuit in in the state of new
york and i think that's super important
this interview that we're going to have
with joe it's really it's it's a fun
interview you guys are going to love it
i know you guys out there on twitter
love jojo from jurors we had such a fun
time um stick right here with us
right after this break uh we'll have the
interview with joe stay right with us
[Music]
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today droop be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back
to the show
we have a special guest with us the
social media extraordinaire jojo from
jurors joe how are you i have a few
questions to start out
i i want to ask you about becky sue
because i don't know
she hasn't he hasn't been real motivated
lately yeah i mean she doesn't want to
speak on joe rogan
i don't think i i don't think she
probably watches that i don't know i
think she's just a little too
disconnected to watch that stuff i don't
know
she was gonna watch she know what
podcasting is does she know what
podcasts are well no because she thinks
that everything's a vlog so she thinks
you probably think a podcast has
something to do with like laundry
detergent like that that's perfect
that's perfect yeah i don't know i don't
wash my clothes with those podcasts
i just usually
we're already we're already developing a
rogan video like i don't know who this
joe rogan is but i'm not hurt
okay
yeah my daddy's daddy uses rogaine but i
don't know
i just got an idea because gabe played
rogan on an rnn sketch that we did
and you played becky sue on an rnn
sketch maybe what we should do
is have rogan
you on joe rogan's show becky sue on joe
rogan's show
okay i like that that's what we should
do
you should do something like that yeah
because gabe makes gabe makes a perfect
um joke yeah you know i got a cigar and
i got a ball cap it's pretty uncanny
i can see that exactly looks exactly
like the hair that comes out of the hair
the bald cap yeah yeah cause i really
don't give a [ __ ] i'm just like yeah put
it on cool let's go
yeah yeah we definitely you definitely
gotta have the hair hanging out so it
looks yeah oh yeah because he looks
cheesy oh god
i can't stand him you wanna see the
apology video like like here's a guy who
like for a living he sits in front of a
microphone and a camera and records
himself and he did such a shitty job at
recording that
he always whenever he does the videos he
always is uh
he's got that thumb face going on yeah
he's right underneath the camera yeah
right he's like
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know i'd really like
him
listen here's the context of when i said
the n word it's like we didn't need any
context right you said it so that was
enough you heard what they're doing
today so they're blaming they're blaming
it all on midas touch and the mizellas
brothers really because yeah we even
entered the chat they in the in the
thread
and the thread they pulled a clip from
the show that we had brett and jordy on
and they put that in the clip like see
look here this is more evidence like we
were talking about we were playing
trivia in the clip right like literally
like of course we say like stop the
steal and we were joking you know but
but it it's like oh my god you people
are [ __ ] out of your minds like
literally it is not a secret that
patriot takes is with mind as touch and
patriot takes did not make it a secret
that they made the video yeah it's it's
the the one tweet that you sent me was
they're like oh this is what's uh they
said like oh they're uh their background
is in marketing and whatever right like
masters of manipulation and stuff and
what's important to know
is that brett used to work as a as an
editor social media person for ellen and
that's important because dot dot and
then like posted these two article like
screenshots of when they got featured in
like variety or something right which
and
which is also like
nobody
altered the video i said those things
it's on the internet it's not like they
had to go inside like a storage room to
find these things or something right
right exactly like yeah he had them up
that was him he said it so you're mad at
people attacking him for him saying
stuff but not mad
that he said
right
and it's hilarious that
today they're attacking howard stern
like see he said the n-word too
and it's like okay well if you're mad at
him if you're mad at him stern for
saying it
then you must be mad at rogan but you're
not so like like decide which one you
want and and gabe gabe sent me was he
yeah you sent me the rock thing like
when the rock
you send it to me in a dm and i'm like
dude it's
rogan's over like this yeah i didn't see
so i saw a reference to the rock and
rogan but i did not see what happened so
it was uh well it was somebody mashed up
two clips together so basically it was
the rock from the 90s early 2000s in
there and he does is like
like he's doing like a chinese like
right oh yeah that video well that's
what he did and then the person cut it
to rogan on the side commenting ufc was
like oh whoa
well you know that's what happened right
but the rock was defending rogan
right right right but it was tim tim
poole
then started sharing these videos of
like i'm so glad the rocks uh the rock
stood up against racism and then posted
that clip from back when
and then people started cutting clips
together
and then there's stuff then then i also
shared with you like uh
tyt the the young church
where they say the n word it doesn't
matter like doesn't matter the context
they still set it on the air right
and people are like oh well the left's
not going after i'm like everyone should
get called out if they said this word
like i don't know why it's and then you
decide left or right it's you said it
it's bad right right there's no context
for it especially here actually when
this is what i tweeted yesterday i think
it was yesterday it all blends together
but especially when you when you have
said it so many times that someone can
splice together a compilation that's
minutes long of you saying it it's like
there's could not be enough context on
the planet earth to cover your ass for
that like you shouldn't say once let
alone have a compilation video that
they've possibly made it's just
ridiculous i can't you're like listen i
can i can explain why i said it and it's
like no don't just
well like you're saying joe if you if
you had one clip of you saying it there
might be context of what you could
explain right but like it's over and
over and over again and the other thing
too is it's like a hard rock too it's
like right okay right right and
the other thing too is he had all this
stuff like some of the stuff that made
in that video he had it in his stand up
for like two years this isn't like he
was like being recorded by someone in a
room where he was talking privately the
dude was in front of a microphone in
front of a camera knowing what he was
saying recording it and then he would
publish it like yeah he would
intentionally publish it so it's not
like he didn't know that he didn't say
this stuff and yeah he he talks a lot so
he probably forgets a lot of stuff that
he says but when you when you get
recalled with your content that's on the
internet with a video that's spliced
together you know you said it it's not
like some kind of [ __ ] deep state
kind of thing where they're deep faking
him saying this [ __ ] it's him and he
even admits in the apology even i'm
embarrassed yeah and then his apology
about planet of the apes is even worse i
mean it's even worse it's like
no i didn't i would never compare you
just did compare them to eight you
literally you made a joke
yeah you laughed
at the expense
of african americans like that's what it
was yeah so up to the lead up to the
apology though because the rock
you know everyone was going after
spotify which i have my own opinion on
that which we can talk about
sorry i see that video now yeah
so so that everyone was on the spotify
thing right yeah and then and then the
rock had kind of defended him and don
winslow which i'm not always a fan of
but don calls him out
on twitter
and says hey man
you're really defending racism here and
post the patriot takes
uh compilation of him saying the n word
and then the rock immediately like
like a gangster freaking just says he
said he he moves the conversation from
delete spotify
and it's the platform's problem to know
this is a joe rogan problem and he moves
it straight to this argument of of of
racism and you shouldn't be saying this
stuff and we shouldn't be listening to
people who are saying this stuff and the
rock did a beautiful job as he always
does yeah and like immediately i'm like
oh he's [ __ ] done like this whole
boycott spotify thing i'm like you're
not that's not gonna work it's not gonna
work he's getting paid a hundred million
bucks spotify is making a [ __ ] ton of
money off the [ __ ] he's saying to the
people he's saying it to you yeah but
when ro the rock entered the
conversation i'm like oh my god you are
[ __ ] you are done son you are over
you might and that's what the apology
was about he might as well
his apology should have been this if he
wanted to do a video i'm a comedian it
was comedy get the [ __ ] over it yeah
it is what he should have said i mean
that's literally what he was trying to
say
but
i i think i think it's i think it's a
situation where
um
yeah i mean like he could say like hey
listen i'm a comedian and he could be
like uh you know in retrospect like it
wasn't a great joke i shouldn't have
said it you know at the time you know
i thought it was funny however
since then i have changed matured and
realized
uh it's not okay to say obviously
doesn't really help out because he just
kept saying it for years right right so
it's hard for you to be like i did it in
a bit and it was like in the moment and
that was it and it wasn't just like one
time it was like oh he did it did it did
it he kept doing it again and again and
it wasn't just that thing because then
there's all the other stuff that came
out which is like oh my god kind of you
know take advantage of women sexual
rules
and that and it's like
it's like when you start telling
everything up it's not so great and it's
hard for someone to be like i'm just a
comedian it's like man you might just be
a shitty person i don't know
well right but but i mean what other
arguments does he have at this point
that's going to keep because they've
already they've already which which is
the best part that he's like oh spotify
doesn't cancel me and his audience is
like no cancel culture and get to say
whatever you want and spotify deletes a
hundred episodes like 110 yeah right
right it wasn't 110 because it was 70
and then it went to 100.
yeah now i think it's at 110 well
there's that there's that what is it
g-a-g-r-e tracking 113 episodes are
missing from spotify last check four
minutes ago
so
so now it's 113. well so because
originally when he moved to spotify
spotify bought all the episodes but they
they they canned like 12 of them i think
11 or 12 of them they hand
um so they they wouldn't even touch
those episodes but they touched all the
ones that you know uh yeah that
obviously patriot takes got his hands on
to uh to make that video so yeah
i i you know i don't know um
exactly what happens with spotify and
rogan but i know spotify's got a lot of
choices to make when um and rogan's got
a lot of choice to make because man you
can't you're not going to be able to run
around this country pissing off someone
like rock that the rock i mean dwayne
johnson there's no [ __ ] way the dude
is too [ __ ] i mean he makes he he
swings hard in hollywood now like he is
paid i think he's the highest paid actor
in hollywood right
there and then there was that
interaction with uh
sherry jacobs right where he went at her
and was like hey you're all of my time
that was yesterday right that was
yesterday it was two two days ago three
days ago okay it was like hey don't be
so triggered and everyone's like uh
not great like don't
say that about a woman joe rogan said
though no no this is a rock because
and
then he was like i'm sure and you know i
don't want to speak for him but i'm sure
like at the moment he's like getting
[ __ ] from everyone and she was one
person who's like you need to say
something and he was like
uh
don't be so triggered and everyone's
like
don't do that
and then yesterday he came out with
apologies like listen
i just want to say i'm sorry i apologize
i shouldn't have done that and actually
like and here's the thing like
right you look at this weekend and this
weekend was like full of apologies it
was joe brogan making an apology it was
aquafina making an apology it was the
rock making an apology
uh and then making another apology but
then like in the second apology to her
he like owned up and he's like listen i
apologize i'm sorry i should have said
that you you got the the wrong end of of
my day
and
we you know you don't deserve that and
like you know i've got a i've got a big
voice and it's important to use it
and i was like wow that was that's
pretty good you don't really see
a lot of people do that you know in
terms of like owning up to being like oh
[ __ ] like
i'm gonna i'm gonna make up for what i
just did here
he said that
rogan's response was contrite
and more importantly open to change to
become better was that the one two was
that the one to her originally or was
that yeah i guess so hi sherry good
morning it's dj you're all over my
timeline so i wanted to share some
context with you so hopefully you're no
longer triggered by headlines you read i
thought his response was contrite and
more importantly open to change to
become better and then i see her
response to him but i don't see him
responding to her again oh no he made it
i think he made a separate tweet on its
own oh okay and so he just made it like
here's a tweet and i'm tagging her in it
and then she responded and then
everyone's like oh this is amazing
yeah people can have actual dialogue and
not go at each other like is this what
like is this what being civil looks like
because that's what it was right it was
like oh that's crazy two people were
able to have
a difference of opinion in the moment
and then own up and be like oh actually
i was wrong i'm sorry right and like
that he said he said um
i didn't show up the way i would have
liked to in our dialogue and my language
to you was offensive not
if you found my language offensively
because that's the [ __ ] ploy that
people pull all the time i'm sorry you
feel that way yeah right who says uh it
was offensive and i apologize good okay
i have opinions about spotify i posted a
message today i'm like i'm not gonna
de-platform myself
you know i i've seen so many people the
platform themselves from spotify that
have voices against rogan and i'm like
you know people people deleting their
spotify account their personal spotify
account to where they don't give their
money to
spotify i'm all for that that that makes
that makes sense but for people who have
a voice against rogan who are who are
trying to combat that [ __ ] like
inside the space of noise right like if
you go to a protest and you're
protesting nazis and nazis show up and
you're like well i'm not gonna do this
anymore because they're here like well
what the [ __ ] i mean you have to you
have to go belly to belly with this
stuff and right i was so disappointed to
see some people and i'm not gonna name
them but i was so disappointed to see
some people that de-platformed myself
because what's gonna happen
is that less people are gonna hear their
message which is very disappointing
because those messages are super
important like to democracy like not
just not just to the whole rogan's a
[ __ ] clown like literally this these
fascists are clinging to rogan for a
reason yeah that's the whole point
right so i was a little disappointed to
see that they would walk away um from
that platform because not only is it
just spotify but spotify owns like half
the podcast universe which you know i
don't know if that's right wrong or
indifferent but we do live in the
capitalist country so that's just it's
the [ __ ] system we got it's kind of
like citizens united you either play
ball or you [ __ ] lose right so
i i i my stance is is that um especially
with like the musicians because the
musicians i completely understand um not
not that necessarily their their voice
is going to
matter so much in the political space
but for someone who has political
commentary like we do on this show i
mean we clown them a lot but we do
try to have a serious conversation about
the politics of everything to
de-platform my message or anyone else
who gets downloaded way more than we do
to de-platform themselves i think it's a
disservice um not only to the people who
want to listen but to our democracy like
it is important that some of those
voices be heard and when they decline
from themselves they don't they don't
like it's hundreds of thousands
of ears that don't get to hear that
message i don't know
they're not gonna go away from spotify
the point it was to get them to drive
them away from spotify but they're
probably not going to do that they're
just like you said they're just going to
find what they are there to find anyway
right well i mean i mean the the
the object is to get joe rogan in a
place where joe rogan decides if he's
going to continue to make this shitty
[ __ ] content that is ruining
parts of what i think is the fabric of
society like he's
he's injecting um massive misinformation
to people
and they're acting on it it's not like
you know it's a funny joke like this
isn't a funny [ __ ] joke anymore like
you're it's not you're not a comedian at
this point and i guess that's the point
i was trying to make with he you know
his statement he basically should have
just said i'm a comedian [ __ ] you you
know what are you gonna do about it and
and and move on with it and just
continue to do what you're gonna do
um but
now that the rock is entered the
conversation and i hate that it has to
be that way because
someone was waiting for a heavy hitter
to come in
and really um
show joe rogan how to handle the
situation and i think the rock is doing
that um regardless of the back and forth
that he had i think he's doing that so
i hope that goes well but yeah
i wish we lived in a world where there
was no joe rogan
that's all
i mean every guy that i have dated and
met in the last three years has been a
rogue listener and it's just oh my god
so annoying they're all sucking their
own dicks
well dave always rejected the dick
i mean yeah you can't
you can't get rid of it right like he
said he's like
dude or like i yeah
yeah
well you know it in in the rnn sketch
where gabe does rogan
um he is at the beginning of it when
rogan shows up he is uh making some you
know
noises that sound like fellatio
um
and then at the end you know just wrap
it up you know
so that is that is in the clip because
actually we weren't going to put that in
the clip and it was like what that day
that we recorded yeah and i was like
yeah we were doing it and i was like
what if i just start with it like right
out of the gate i'm going to go into
town
or go home but i was like holding my own
head down you know
you don't [ __ ] around
yeah i mean you can love yourself but
hey valentine's day is around the corner
so
[Laughter]
oh my god
all right enough of the the [ __ ] talk
i said no one ever
[Laughter]
that's what she said okay are you ready
to play trivia are you ready i'm i was
born ready okay gabe are you are you
ready to play trivia i am ready
let's do this
[Music]
i'm gonna ask you both five multiple
choice questions each question is worth
one point the first one to ring in on
their buzzer give a thumbs up will get a
chance to answer the question get it
wrong and your opponent will have a shot
for the point whoever has the most
points after five questions wins are you
guys ready let's play question number
one it's often regarded as one of the
best video games of its generation
what gaming platform did goldeneye 007
debut on
a playstation
b n64
c sega dreamcast or d sega saturn
playstation i'm sorry that is incorrect
rock
i want to say
i want to say sega genesis
incorrect what are you coming on guys
damn n64 oh it was in 64.
oh you never played it i don't like
i don't like
person games i love video games don't
like first person shooters i don't like
that perspective that that was like the
first
like first person shooter big the big
one yeah yeah first yeah
the reason why they had it on n64 now
that i'm remembering this is because of
the 64 bits right because they had to
have that to accomplish the don't
[Music]
you know
it's a long time ago it was a long time
all right all right well the squad 0-0
full disclosure though i did own a sega
genesis also we had an n64 at one point
but i don't think we actually had that
game i'm so old i had an atari wow
look at that what was your favorite
atari game pitfall i pack pac-man or
miss pac-man which whichever one no you
want to really sleep where you swinging
on the vines in the jungle and then it
goes down that was pitfall right yeah
thank you
and frogger loved frogger oh frogger
yeah that's it that was a fun pc one for
me
yeah yeah yeah my first pc was a
commodore 64. whoa
wow
but those those keyboards were pretty
dope those springs
you could make it say hi if you spent
like two hours programming it yeah you
could make it say hi and like text
anyway sorry i digress go ahead
all right question number two
which danish norwegian band released the
song barbie girl in 1997 a abba b
vanilla ice c aqua or d bjork process of
elimination it has to be c that is
correct
[ __ ] you tony
[Music]
the late 90s had some real hits you know
oh yeah that's an ivanka trump
soundtrack
is it really well i mean i just said it
was like i guess she was a professional
wrestler is that what she would like
come in as yes that's what she when
she's like when she's coming out with
cans of goya
[Laughter]
now
i'm i'm ready to win now i'm going to
taste all right
now now that she's got her fangs in yeah
she's going to she's locked in
boom
all right question number three in the
tv sitcom boy meets world what is the
name of corey matthews best friend a
sean b george c topanga or d eric
sean that is correct
that's what i was gonna say
[Music]
he randomly followed me on twitter i
noticed a while ago yeah the actor yeah
yeah oh okay what's the actual name
writer strong writers junking not now
he's in he's in the girls meet world
right there's a girl right or strong no
i don't think he was in the girl meets
world was he i don't know i mean it was
i never watched corey tapanga
maybe you watch it either
yeah uh
i mean all the main people were in i
forget if his character was in there and
then there's also eric his brother i
don't know if he was in there as well
i haven't really seen him do much he
does not um
so so joe
what was yours
give me a father
you heard it here tag him
so so joe what was your favorite tgif
sitcom because there were several what
was your favorite i'm a little old
yeah yeah
to be honest um
i'm 47. so it was already it was already
too young for me so i was not watching i
i wasn't watching that was the abc
lineup right
like i grew up on um
like the love boat and
disney island and [ __ ] like that
but
but there was a wave before tgif that on
abc like growing pains was on abc
and that was a great show
yeah well until it jumped this way it
was like that was like tgif before dj
like that was the
model right the model show right right
well that's my more my generation
isn't it and it's sad though like
growing pains like you look at some of
the uh some of the actors and growing
pains like what's his what's up leonardo
uh religious videos like propaganda
religiously oh he's an evangelical
christian activist yeah
so you know
wait wait his sister like his real
sister are on the show sister
his real sister is cameron
cameron bury how do you say her name cam
she's uh the one who used to be on the
view and she started out on full house
and then he came back with full time is
cameron burr
that's it so that's his sister she's
ultra ultra ultra conservative uh
evangelical like leaning
yeah she's the zillionaire now um but
yeah i don't like any of them
so like a cool person then huh that
you'd not
she's living off that full house money
isn't she well there's that and she's
like clothing lines oh [ __ ] but her
sweden who played um her sister on the
full and fuller house is the complete
opposite politically and she's awesome i
don't know if she follows me
is she the one that had
the meth addiction yes yep that's jody
sweet yeah right
later revealed in her memoir that she
was high during it so
do you remember her being high or you
just remember no i didn't i wasn't there
i didn't see it but in her memory i got
uh i think it was like talking about a
recovery in her like life through
oh [ __ ] like acting and going through it
and then it turns out she was still
using
but i wasn't there i only know about it
because it was uh it was mentioned in
the paper because she had this whole
thing about how she was high
at my school when she was there to speak
so
wow that's really sad oh man
thanks for pepping up the room gabe yeah
well you know
90s uh you know
oh my god it's so bad all of them so
anyway on that note
uh
question number four
jump off the bridge already
listen if anyone out there still
listening and still subscribe to the
show we've got question 4 coming up
right now
let's go to question 4 then which
1991 movie became the first animated
film to be nominated for the academy
award for best picture a aladdin b the
lion king c pocahontas or d beauty and
the beast joe
the lion king
i'm sorry
that is incorrect what were the choices
again
a aladdin yeah be the lion king okay c
pocahontas sure d beauty and the beast
if you get this right i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you okay i don't i don't know i i'm
gonna take a sabbath i i wanna go with
one of them that seems obvious but i'm
gonna go with pocahontas i'm sorry that
is also incorrect the answer is beauty
and the beast
the animated film that basically is
about stockholm syndrome
well you know the reason why i thought
maybe pocahontas because like if you
watch that film like the art and
everything in it um especially um the
colors of the wind like when they do
that part of like it is that that is
like actually a phenomenal
piece of art i thought maybe that that
was it but a bit of revisionist
storytelling as well but you know that
is what it is well i mean
disney new revision come on
come on
you never did revisions
yeah yeah
i took a class in college for
linguistics
and we studied um different
uh we had a part where we studied
different um songs that were done
throughout culture like through the 20th
century and we went through and
discussed the
some some of the original aladdin songs
and oh boy they are racist like
they are right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's not good
well yeah yeah and yeah like
no no no no that like the uh i forget it
was the robin williams song but it was
the one that was talking about jafar and
some others it was basically like
stereotyping people like in a desert in
the middle east stuff like that i was
like
not great obviously didn't make the
final cut but the fact that they wrote
it i was like oh so this is songs that
aren't in the uh no no no they're not
they did not make the final cut they
were written and had been released and
then we were studying
basically the
the negative so did they not make it in
the movie because of that or they're
just shitty songs
well i mean i think they're shitty songs
because they you know right racism but
uh right but i'm saying like like you
know there's catchy songs and then
there's no i think actually the that's
it might have made it in the movie but
they like
did a complete like refresh of lyrics to
that melody and song i got you i guess
so i'm trying to remember i mean this is
years ago when i took the class but i do
remember specifically this part where
they're like we're gonna go over some
like you know lyrics and and study the
words that were written and everyone's
like oh that's not good
oh yeah
all right well on that note uh question
five game just bring down the goddamn
room it's like this game is
super lighthearted right and and we are
totally [ __ ] it up
we're still like we're on question 20
and we're still trying oh boy
then i should not go into question five
right now
let's do it you want question five let's
do it
here we go further down the rabbit hole
of darkness
question number five princess diana
tragically died in a car crash in 1997
in which city i told you i didn't it
just happened that way
she's already got it she knows
yeah two come on i'm getting cheated the
score is wonder i always lose two to one
two to one all right those are five
questions i did include an extra two if
you guys want to go through oh let's
what these are these are like these are
like dancing
we really go up from here
so wait wait you took the good questions
and you stuck them on the babies we had
to start low and then we like built our
way up you know joe do you see what i
gotta deal with do you see what i gotta
do it's going right here it's going up
don't worry
all right here we go question six
dolly was the name of the world's first
mammal cloned from a somatic cell which
animal was dolly oh well it's okay ready
to go sheep boom got it uh
yeah that would make sense they're all
clones of each other yeah
they all have some stupid sunglasses on
the back of their heads right and they
got those like coakley like little you
know attachments you know all right
question number seven
in which 1990s film did macaulay culkin
play the main character kevin mcallister
my daughter was obsessed with this movie
when she was four she watched it every
single day and it's home alone obviously
home alone that is correct wow sorry
it's ridiculous
home alone home loan two by the way
final score four to one
joe
wins crushed it [ __ ] crushed it
i didn't even have to i didn't even get
to say the multiple choice she already
knew she was like i know i know
i guess that she wasn't drunk through
all the 90s
luckily for for your four-year-old you
you
you beat my ass
in trivia thanks for playing trivia with
us and thanks for gabe for making it
bright and shiny with the uh with the
1990s death
racism
we really appreciated
maybe the 90s weren't so great i don't
know
[Music]
all right fantastic i'm glad you're with
my ass to that song yeah yeah yeah get
used to it
[Music]
she's just gonna pop in for random shows
and be like oh oop oop answer the
question and then tony's just gonna lose
it's going to happen it's going to
happen well other guests won't even have
a chance she just comes and answers the
questions she's like spoiler alert the
answer is
it is very comforting to know that i was
not the first person you beat so that is
something i will that i am very proud of
i i you i still am on a losing streak
from the very beginning i don't know how
many trivies we've done but we've done a
lot of them and and gabe plays you know
we we switch back and forth you know
i'll play the game plays and i play and
gay plays and now we did have uh
the mizellas brothers on one time um
and and they played each other and that
clip actually got resurfaced today we
were talking about this earlier it got
resurfaced today
with the joe rogan story believe it or
not
because the they're they're blaming the
brogan thing on midas touch it's some
kind of you know conspiracy but because
we interviewed him
do you think they searched the game how
do you think they found that clip
they're like i don't know i'm sure they
i'm sure somebody like because the
person was like references referencing
articles that they had been quoted in or
spotless that had been done on them and
so i'm sure that they're like oh if we
can find any video of them
saying anything then we will show and it
turns out we will play trivia
we were playing trivia on the podcast
right the clip that's crazy tell us
about your your twitter account and tell
us because um you have
like well over
200 000 now right
yeah i think yeah
yeah it's 2 36 7.
whoo
because you're just you're just as
savage on on the twitter timeline as you
were in the in the trivia like you're
just saying yeah
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much um i am not that proud of my
performance in the trivia just so you
know uh i cleaned it up at the end
[Laughter]
yeah uh no i i got on twitter in
2017 like a lot of people i think
to um
to vent about
trump and to
i all i wanted to do because i live in a
very conservative very mega heavy
section of new jersey i call it new
jersey west virginia here that's how we
have a not soup nazi
um
no everywhere i'll tell you real quick
quick story to preface this so the day
after the election there were student
teacher conferences at school and i went
to my son's conference he was in
kindergarten i guess and people were
partying
on the front lawn of the school there
were like legitimate high-five parties
like they were tailgating celebrating
trump's win
that's where i live so
so
that day i think pretty much i was like
you know what
i'm getting off of facebook i can't do
this because it was everybody was all
pro-trump and it was just killing me and
i felt like i was
surrounded so i got off facebook for the
most part and then
i was like you know what i'm not i need
to find people who think like me and
what's this twitter thing all about
so i wanted to go on and like make fun
of him because i i just wanted to tell
him things that made me feel better that
were very sophomoric and so my first
couple tweets i just said like i'm sorry
you have to see yourself naked
and like
yeah so i think my first ever tweet was
to trump and i was i'm sorry you have to
see yourself naked and then i think my
second tweet ever was you have old balls
i think that's how i started
perfect start by the way yeah right out
yeah yeah yeah and i had zero followers
didn't know how twitter worked i didn't
even this is a very fun fact that i've
only told a few people and it's super
embarrassing
so i didn't understand how twitter
worked um so i was trying to craft
tweets and i couldn't figure out how to
make a new line of text i don't know if
you guys have ever noticed that this is
stupid but what i do when i tweet often
is i do it in sort of a way where
there's like separate lines of text i
like the way that looks
but part of the reason i do it that way
is because of what i discovered that you
could hit the return button and get a
new line of text it was so mind-blowing
it took me almost a year to figure that
out yeah
liberating i'm sure oh my god so this is
everything everyone listening this is
why joe's tweets are line by line by
line because she can and it sort of
became like my my signature thing
accidentally because i was like [ __ ]
return return look a whole new line of
text so yeah so yeah and um
i guess i started making a name for
myself because i was getting alerts for
text for trump's tweets so i could jump
on them to be the first one just like
like go after him and people started
noticing that i had a potty mouth and
all this other stuff and so that's how
it started
so you really hated his old balls like
from the very beginning and that's you
took advantage of that and that's why
where why we have jojo from jersey
yeah
yeah i mean i don't want to think about
his balls but there was that scene from
big daddy
there's a scene from big daddy where
adam sandler discovers his girlfriend's
cheating on him with the old man and
that's what he says and it was one of
the funniest lines i've ever seen in
movies and the way he delivered it was
like you have old
balls and that was how i thought what i
would want to say to trump just that
like if i could say nothing else
so yeah so like or had an opportunity if
you had an opportunity to stand like toe
to toe with trump that's the first thing
yeah you know what yeah and i and you
know it would really probably bother him
because he would think like this woman's
going to be like attracted to him or
something and i don't i yeah i would be
like you have old
balls
and then just look at him up and down
and kind of like shake my head and walk
away
would be very cool
for the adam adam sandler quote from me
yeah
yeah i yeah i'm a 12 year old trapped in
a 47 year old woman's body unfold
yeah so that
that wasn't
i don't know if that was your question
but that was what i told you
that's fantastic that is an answer that
is an answer and and the audience is
gonna yeah and the audience is going to
enjoy the the evolution from yeah the
facebook to the twitter knowing that you
you were making sure to let donald trump
know about his old balls and then
discovering the line
thing you know the the line
i really changed everything so what was
other significant parts that explains
why it took a full year to get um so in
the early days
political twitter obviously was
completely electrified and then i
happened to get lucky enough to catch
george conway's attention
i was i didn't know who he was really i
didn't i knew who kellyanne was but i
didn't know anything about george conway
or whatever and then he started he
always teases me because he did my
podcast he always teases me when i say
this but to me
he was a very big
igniting factor in political twitter
because he was
from the inside sort of and he was going
right for the jugular with trump and it
was funny and i liked his style and i
liked what he had to say and then we
sort of became twitter friends but he he
noticed my tweets and he started
amplifying them and then the big big big
thing that happened was i had a tweet uh
it was called lost trump history and it
was a hashtag and it was right after uh
sharpiegate so all these people had
already baked in memes with all the
sharpie stuff where they had altered
pictures with sharpies like you know
this the height of obama and all this
other stuff
so i started this hashtag because trump
had said he was down at nine at ground
zero moving removing rubble and it
pissed me the [ __ ] off because it was
like no you don't get yet to [ __ ]
claim that you disgusting piece of [ __ ]
you were not there there were people
that died that you know all these people
that suffered lost lives lost loved ones
all that like i was so mad that i didn't
know what to do with that anger so i
started a funny hashtag to kind of calm
myself down
where it was like okay so trump
trump did you know that trump was the
first person to circumnavigate the globe
it's true
what other little-known facts
do you would you like to share about
trump
lost trump history and it
it was like
he discovered uh you know the moon
you know heats whatever you name it and
now all these people started hashtagging
it and then that made it into
the washington post and people magazine
and that that was like the big big one i
got 10 000 followers from that so that
was fun this is how you become famous
yeah look it up because you will laugh
your ass off it's still a great thread
it's a great great thread it's funny as
[ __ ] it's so funny and it's not me how
many days how many days does it take to
go through this thread like as you're
laughing because
it was trending number one for an entire
day
the whole day
it's but it's so worth it because
it's so worth it it's so funny it's just
and back then actually i was tweeting
from a different hand no then i was
tweeting from jojo from jurors i think
but before that i was just tweeting at
my name
and then i changed it um i changed it
because i had sort of a stalker
situation but whatever that's dumb now
hopefully
so yeah and then i started tweeting as
jojo from jurors instead of my name
which is
gabe's looking up these tweet threads
right now yeah i gotta find these
threads i've got the huffington post
article pulled up right now oh
trump's 911 hilarious lost trump history
meme
oh my god yeah so george george tweeted
me out with this hashtag and then it
just it it flew
it like it was crazy he he was good at
that he was good at getting viral
threads like he did the you guys have to
look this one up too but trump greeting
cards was really funny that was
[ __ ] hysterical um
you got to look all that up it's good
stuff
kind of nothing gabe knows nothing about
making up trump things like at all like
yeah he doesn't do i don't
i would never do anything making it
about trump what that's crazy who's
watching
well that was why that very first time i
saw that new statement that was the one
that the new one that you did i was like
gabe
david
yeah i i tried when i did the first one
i responded to people and i was like
you know like kind of gave it away there
and then this time through when i did
the most recent one after pence made the
you know his little like trump is wrong
statement
um i was like i'm not gonna say anything
now i'm just gonna let people respond
how they want and then it ended up
getting in the hands of uh daniel dale
and he was like this is not real and i
was like
thank you for fact checking me
whatever
you you know
that's a big deal
yeah yeah and i like if daniel dale
wants to come on i i daniel dale is
great i no no no no i don't like
yeah it's not like i don't like him or
anything i just found it funny that he
had a fact check right fake press yeah
right can you imagine can you imagine
though like like because daniel dale did
the country service by tracking down
every like every time trump spoke like
every single time he said anything
tweeted anything any kind of statement
right daniel dale he was he had i don't
know like what kind of energy drinks he
was drinking but he had to be up like 28
hours a day or some [ __ ] to do that he's
like he said this and then he's like
or he's he claimed this and he's like he
didn't do it he didn't do it he didn't
do it like there was that point where
cnn and i don't know if it was him that
was behind it or someone else but for a
while uh the chirons at cnn updated
where he would like trump would trump
like claimed whatever and then it would
be like in parentheses no we didn't
i had to factor with him like in real
time because he was couldn't keep up you
couldn't go back in in fact so i will
say you know thank you to daniel dale
and all the hard work that he put in and
i appreciate i take it as a badge of
honor though he probably doesn't like me
for this very fun you know
if anyone out there knows daniel dale or
he follows you or you're up in the dm's
of daniel tell him we are we are more
than willing to have him
come on the show
we would love to have him on the show
and ask him about the maybe maybe real
maybe not uh gabe trump's statement that
that is
that you know people today's game
i think i actually here's what i think
happened joe and we're going to talk
about this live on the podcast so this
is already going to be aired before we
talk here here's what i think happened
because the trump statement was [ __ ]
ridiculous and you can tell trump didn't
actually write it like you can tell he
didn't write it it was you know
so here's what i think happened
he wanted to put a statement up by
for mike pence
maybe gabe maybe not gabe put out a
statement that may have or may not look
like trump's statement
and trump had a statement that was like
exactly that
like like it was so close to what it was
written because he was like oh [ __ ] like
blew up your whole [ __ ] game so
someone else had to write this statement
like that's that's what i want to have
happen so badly
it's like gabe's game maybe gabe or not
gave statement that was written
possibly was so close to what he wanted
to write that they had to come up with
this weird wacky
you know it was all over the map because
i was surprised as soon as the statement
went out and i was like i was doing some
stuff and i was like oh i should just
like write some like whatever nonsense
kind of statement saying that no you're
wrong you know kind of thing and i like
typed it up boom send it out tweeted it
done and this is probably like 20
minutes after he he get like after that
news broke
me when the pits clip came on right when
the pence clip came out i i wrote it and
then i just put it out there it was like
20 minutes or so
and he had he didn't have any sort of
response about it and i was like what's
going on this is so weird and then it
wasn't until hours later in the day that
a new one come out so there might have
been like people were like claiming it
was trump and then liz harrington was
like it's not trump and it's like
it's not i swear in the meanwhile she's
like deleting and like
statement you know
she's gonna use different fonts in their
body when they're writing you know one
has a one's a sans-serif versus a serif
like it's somebody is
paraphrasing what he's saying and then
there's actually him writing it right
so so
joe do you get this a lot like with this
statement that that gay may or may not
have put out um do you get this a lot
with your becky sue character because
she spot on him do you get this a lot
like is this real they think you're real
they say [ __ ] down in the comments like
who is this and i i used to it's
shocking now if i ever get any because
most people know now that in the
beginning it was like
constant and everybody really believed
that this chick was was real which
shocked me and didn't shock me all once
because nothing is beyond parody anymore
like nothing is beyond parody
you can hear these people talking about
how jfk junior is coming back to take
over the republican party and it's like
that's what they're really saying like
they really really think that and you
you could make a video parroting that
person and
people would believe it was real because
people say crazier [ __ ] than that but in
the beginning people were like this
chick is beyond stupid that was painful
to listen to
and then there were
conversations between people like no
this is not real she's she's doing a
parody and then i got
flagged for misinformation and it was
like jesus christ this is satire
yeah i think the ivermectin video the
fourth the first one where i was like
had the shits i think i got flagged for
that
yeah
did you actually have the fights or just
you were you were pretending right you
were pretending i was pretending to have
this okay good i did not have to
you didn't actually eat the iron
i'm not yeah i'm not that committed to
my craft
[Laughter]
something funny has happened since i
began doing that character which was
born out of i don't even know everyone's
like oh you ripped off blair erskine and
i
love her i've done her she's been on my
podcast i absolutely love her yeah
blair's great videos are amazing
yeah but
comparing me to blair isn't really fair
for anybody because just because we're
both making videos they're not even
really similar but whatever and then
maybe she inspired me and that's also a
huge compliment to her so um but blair
and i are like twitter friends so hi
blair um and she's had huge success
she's writing for kimmel i'm so happy
for her but um
anyway
so people uh the funniest thing has
happened where now
people are like she's just so sweet well
she spews this like hate and stupidity
and racist and racism and like she but
she feel like it's so hard to hate her
like she's terrible people like she's
really terrible but don't you think
that's part of the political discourse
that we're going through like the i mean
yet some of it that like well it's hard
to hate my neighbor you know they're
such a good person but god they're so
they say such vile [ __ ] [ __ ] and they
go down to the school board meeting and
they do such vile things right yeah i
mean well yeah
yeah this is a huge problem yeah i mean
it's really hard because some of my
family
voted for trump and every one of my
co-workers and so um
you have this choice to make in your
life where you're like you actually
endorse these horrific things the this
ugly
open xenophobia and racism and and
misogyny you just embrace and enable and
endure endorse all of it and i hate all
of that but how do i interact with you
like you have to
find this space because you can't hate
these people in like just your daily
interactions even though you hate
everything that they uh
embolden and right bad people it's weird
it's hard it's easier on twitter to uh
go off on someone you don't have to see
the grocery store you know what i mean
well
sometimes sometimes twitter feels like a
swamp um and sometimes the grocery
stores these days with all these people
um acting the way they act inside these
grocery stores seems like a swamp too so
um it's almost like sometimes social
media leaks into real life um
unfortunately
and it just uh we're in a situation in
the country like we're all americans
right like this goes back to the right
to vote because we've talked about this
a lot like
democrats
aren't fighting for the right to vote
for democrats like that's not like right
like the democrats in washington are
fighting for the right for even fascists
even even the people who own the nazi
soup kitchen where you live they want
them to have the right to vote like
that's what i want i want the entire
country to be able to vote so we know
like who are we as a people like
obviously we have some sick you know
hillary clinton the email lady got it
correct deplorables that are amongst us
but i mean it's it's a matter of how do
we move forward where a majority can
actually govern and we can do policy
administrate and legislate that policy
with with the majority ideology in this
country because i actually don't believe
that their hateful ideology is
reflective of the majority do you
no
i just think it's incredibly powerful
and enticing for a segment of the
population that needs to hear that the
things that they think that are
ugly
are are valid i think that's so powerful
unfortunately that that's really that
that's their strength i don't think
that's the majority but um
it's very intoxicating for a lot of
people people are tearing apart their
real lives because something
on the internet
yeah it's it's really scary i mean it
permeates every second of people's lives
if you think about it because you can go
to it at any time and you can access
information at any time and people can
find you and access you at any time it
never stops it's it's
i mean it's really scary in that way how
much power it has it has i mean i see
that with my own with my kids yeah like
with my teenage almost teenage son
you know you can't you just
you can't we used to be when we were
kids that you could go home and be in
the cocoon of your home
and turn off whatever had happened to
you maybe at school during your day with
your peers or with the bully or whatever
you could turn it off and um unplug from
it and reset and you can't do that
anymore you know and so it's feeding all
sorts of
the worst in us for sure um in large
measure but it's also
connected a lot of people which is good
and it's a
very powerful tool for good as well i
think um well i think you're right
and i i think you're right and i think i
think you're one of the warriors um out
there
that make sure to stay on top of things
and because i i don't see just jojo from
jurors on her timeline she's in the
comments and she's battling it out she's
she's boxing i mean
pro-democracy set a boxing gloves on and
she's gonna spar
uh in those comments with anybody and
everybody are you not you are not afraid
you go into
a comment thread and and comment under
someone who you definitely do not agree
with is that right
no for sure it's um
and it's funny because you know people
say you're just you're putting it out
there really you're going to change
anybody's minds and you i don't know if
i'm going to change anybody's mind maybe
i will illuminate somebody with
something i say but for me it's the
jersey in me um i'm a fighter and if i
see injustice in particular and this is
whatever but um especially when it comes
to our democracy like i'm a total geek
for
government and democracy and and all of
that so much so that i cry when you know
they sing like the national anthem i'm
that person i love i i very proudly fly
an american flag i'm never gonna let
anybody take that from me i'm not gonna
let anybody claim the flag for
themselves um
so when i see
the kind of things that are happening
right now in particular like putting
trump aside what the republicans are
doing by dismantling the very
foundations of our democracy it gets me
more upset
than almost anything else and so for me
to be able to go at these people in real
time who are doing this dismantlement um
it it's it's important so that's i mean
i get really fired up i really do i
don't and i'm not afraid to fight
so that's how i that's why
we appreciate your fight even if it's
just the one tweet at a time because i'm
i i don't go down the um the rabbit
holes in the comments and and maybe i
should but um
nine times out of ten jojo's been there
you know oh i
right she's always well like she just
like carved it in she's like i was here
right right well you know when we do the
shitless when i do the [ __ ] list roundup
um joe you are you're one of the
favorites because you're always trending
and then anytime i go into uh a thread
you're always right there at the top and
you're [ __ ] giving it to him like we
don't give a [ __ ] yeah we're gonna we're
gonna take this pro-democracy thing
seriously because i because i believe um
you know you have your fun tweets but
almost all
that's what i enjoy about your content
the most is that
you always have this view and you're
looking through the lens of how why
democracy is so important it's not like
liberal or conservative or like you i i
think you truly understand that
it is it is more higher than yourself or
political party or an ideology like this
thing this thing's important without
democracy
um you won't you won't get to have a
political party like you don't get to
have ideas if fascism takes over like
it's going to destroy your communities
your schools your churches um i mean
fascism when it takes over
they they don't allow you to have any
other thoughts and if you do
you are going to regret it or you won't
even know that you regret it right i
mean the people i mean the people who
are like oh you know like who can who
have the ability the freedom to say what
they want and say what they think
whether it's good or bad you know that
will go out the window you know
especially now when they're like oh this
fascist state is taking over uh you know
joe biden's fascism or whatever and it's
like oh baby you don't know what you're
talking right right right go look up the
word yeah so so tell us about it tell us
about when you're writing because i
always like to have people reveal like
their process so like when you're
writing these tweets do you are you just
like pounding on the keyboard and throw
and throw your your thumb on the tweet
button or is there more
strategery behind it i mean what what is
what is the method because
jojo from jurors again does not [ __ ]
around on on the bird app so tell us
tell us the method that you use i mean
what what are you looking for how do you
how do you find these things that are
important to you and what you're
tweeting about
um well at heart i'm a reply guy like
that's the number one thing i've i've
always been a reply guy that's where i
get my motivation my inspiration is
replying to especially you know a lot of
i have my own list of dumbass
republicans that's literally i have a
list in my twitter that's i go to a
couple times a day
just to see what the [ __ ] what other
[ __ ] they're up to and that often
sort of inspires me to craft my own
tweets as responses as a conglomerate to
this [ __ ] that they're doing um
but so so
again my core i was always a reply guy i
always had difficulty kind of crafting
my own original tweets because i didn't
have enough confidence in my voice and
that's not the case as much anymore or
at all although every time i tweet i
think
you know how will this be received which
is the imposter syndrome again um
but uh there are a couple of things that
are super important to me that i've
talked about with other people and and
one of the most important things when
i'm going when i'm approaching how to
tweet something is it has to be
usually a little bit funny like i i
think and i was explaining this to
kimberly johnson i think there's so much
crazy
[Music]
[ __ ] out there right now it's never it's
it's like never stops so it would be
impossible for us to consume all of that
like in big giant in one big bulky piece
so it's easier for me to break things up
into digestible bites and the way to do
that is with a little bit of a chaser of
humor like if you can sort of spin
something terrible so that people feel
like okay well at least i had a little
giggle at the ending of our democracy
like you know this is very dire on the
edge of a cliff but like this is kind of
kind of funny at the same time because
you have to
i think to be sane you have to find a
place where you can take the heaviness
burden and lighten it a little bit which
sounds insane because we are talking
about
you know somebody who incited a
deadliest direction and as sort of
part of an attempted coup and an entire
party being just fine with that like
that's [ __ ] nuts but if you can't
then also sort of say like especially
with this legitimate political discourse
[ __ ] [ __ ] like if you can't laugh
a little bit people are gonna give up
because they can't sustain all the heavy
all the time and we don't want anyone
giving up we want them to be fired up
and motivated and want to keep fighting
because there's you know there's no
other side on the end of this road if we
don't stop what's happening now yeah and
i think that's that's to your yeah
no no continue yeah
well i was just thinking about what you
guys were saying about you know the very
people who think that joe biden is the
fascist and they talk about all this
other stuff and they have no [ __ ]
idea because i listen to this all the
time and i've tweeted about this too at
work this is the conversation every
[ __ ] day the price of chicken the
price of gas the price of this there's
no jobs no one works at starbucks
because biden blah blah blah blah blah
and
all i want to say is
when you [ __ ] wake up and realize
that you let
like literal fascism come in you're not
gonna get to whine about the price of
[ __ ] chicken
no one's gonna eat no one cares so
you're whining now and you're ready to
literally let this this party
completely destroy the framework of this
country thinking that you're going to
somehow benefit from what they're
planning to do and
you're going to be the bottom of the
list of things they want to care about
they're not going to care and so it just
drives me nuts it's like no that's not
important like you don't understand and
it makes me want to scream well also
just in fact
it's just it's go to go to that point
too it's like all these people are like
oh it's joe biden's fault
it's like okay one he
he's not making these private
corporation decisions like they're the
ones making decisions these companies
claim inflation yet their margins have
gone above and beyond what they were
previously so it's like uh if you really
want to talk about these problems maybe
one
do do actual research and not just like
regurgitate word vomit or things that
have been said by right wing media
outlets but also it's like
you know if you really want to learn
more about the economy and how you know
supply demand works and how inflation
works and all these different aspects of
how like uh
the ups and downs of growth and
recession happen within the economy
maybe actually look into that as opposed
to just being like
inflation bad like
it's like you're just
you know you're getting all flustered
and saying the things that you don't
even know anything about so when these
people are like oh fascism it's like
do you actually know what that means
like have you even looked up a
dictionary
is that actually what you're
experiencing right now or is it the fact
that you are frustrated and you don't
understand why there's a problem right
and it's not actually joe biden's fault
but that's not the case and i think to
the other point too is humor
is so important right i think i think
comedy and humor and laughing is a
healing it is very healing for a lot of
people right like i'm in a shitty
situation that i have no real control
over and so i need to
i need to either say something to get it
out there
and hopefully provide some insight but
also like if i'm if i'm on the receiving
end like it is good to be like okay yeah
it [ __ ] sucks but
that was you know that was a funny take
or i did have a little bit of a laugh
there and like i don't feel
as bad as i did before or whatever it
might be but i feel like if you look
throughout history and all the shitty
things that have happened there's always
been people that have in the background
who have thrown out
like bits of humor um for people to like
to kind of like ease the pressure off
you know
and i think it's super important right
in whatever form written video i mean
laughter
yeah laughter is medicine it really is
and
when you're when we're dealing with what
we're dealing with right now it's very
healing
to be able to find some opportunity to
in the midst of all of the crazy to find
a second to to laugh
yeah it's restorative
and when you can't use humor or you
can't say things and joke about
you know the government or whoever
that's when like you know all these
people complain about fascism and like
first amendment all this stuff it's like
if you why as soon as you can't say this
stuff it's gone done like that is when
you've entered and you've now allowed
these people to take over and and
control the narrative and control your
rights the very thing you feared you
allowed to happen you know
yeah yeah and it'll be stripped from you
before you even realize it yeah right
and then it'll be too late and then
you'll go wait a minute i would like to
do that over um and you can't or the
people would be like this is this is
america and they'll be proud of it and
you'll be like you [ __ ] idiot yeah
just wait till you see the price of
chicken just try and get some chicken go
ahead all the rich people that like your
hogwarts are going to get the chicken
you're going to get [ __ ] scraps
they're going to get right garbage
so so a good history lesson in fascism
and i've talked about this a lot
in in 1920s 1930s germany
hitler and the essay not the ss the sa
tried a violent overthrow of a
government in the coup
it was unsuccessful we all know hitler
went to prison he wrote mineconf and
when he came out of prison
um his his
his goal was not to violently overthrow
again not to take
germany
um and the fatherland with violence his
idea was i'll do it inside the
government right and that's what they're
attempting right now i mean they've been
attempting it for a long time but this
is their plan i mean steve bannon has
even said on trader tv we want to take
over and overthrow the election boards
right because they understand why
democracy is a threat to fascism
but here's here's the ultimate point
when hitler did take power the first
people that he murdered was not the jews
the first people he murdered was the
essay that is the first people he
murdered the people who helped try to
overthrow the the the coup before he
went to prison those people who were
still in his movement the essay he
murdered them and the reason why he
murdered them is because he knew that
they would try to overthrow him if he
got out of check because he knew they
were violent so the the people who were
at january 6 the people who run around
complaining about like you're saying gas
chicken whatever the [ __ ] you're
complaining about
you're going to be the first one that
are going to feel
the the thunder
when when when it comes to fascism like
you're the first one
rachel bickover's been on the show she
calls them breakfast your family's gonna
turn into breakfast narcs
and that is how it's going to work like
that literally is going to be if you let
fascism take over in your local
communities you will not have your
churches you will not have your chambers
of commerce you won't have your little
picnics anymore these are not things
that you're going to have they're going
to do away with all of that because all
of that is not what they want which is
control yeah yeah they don't send all
those little people they're just they're
pawns to them you know like if you think
of it like a game of chess it's like why
do you think all of them are in the
front lines the ones that they let break
in the ones that they let do these
things this illegal activity to test the
bounds of democracy and justice and what
we have in this country they're willing
to let those people
die by the wayside so they can then
clear the way and get great quick we've
got the path to go forward and
the the death and casualty and
collateral damage was not done on
ourselves it was done by the people that
were following us and
believed
our message
right yeah they and their party in the
in the death rows of extinction because
they uh it's you know white male
dominated party and the american
demographic shift
is not favorable to them
so they know that legitimate voting and
democracy itself does not sustain their
existence and so they will do
anything including and of course
dismantling that because they would like
to stay in power so that they have power
for the sake of power not to govern they
have no intentions of governing and it's
crazy they're not even running
on anything that's promising that
they'll govern they're literally just
running on put us in power keep us in
power because we represent you we look
like you that means whites
and so you need to keep us in power
we're not promising to do anything for
you because we're not going to do
anything for you but we want to be in
power so that we can retain our you know
authority over this country as god
intended it and it's [ __ ] nuts
absolutely that's crazy can i tell you
something about the the white male
because i am a white male and here's
what i'll tell you here's the news with
their accuracy here's what the ultimate
thing that they're scared of
is that they're scared if they give
equality
that they will be oppressed like like
they want to oppress others does that
make sense right so like they are
terrified they are terrified that oh my
god if we let if we let people color or
women have power they will oppress us
like we want to oppress them like
they'll figure this stuff out and
they'll totally oppress us like and
that's where this whole begging for
oppression [ __ ] comes from this i can't
get a cheeseburger without a vaccine and
all this [ __ ] oh it's it's the holocaust
and it's segregation all this
self-oppression [ __ ] that's where all
this comes from because if they appear
to be the oppressed now they can preempt
the oppression that will come or some
[ __ ] you know it's all delusion right of
course because um
really there is no more patriotic group
of people in this country than than
black people and
white folks out there listening you're
just lucky that they want equality and
they want equity and they don't want
revenge and i believe they don't and
they just want to
equity they just want equality so stop
acting like you're oppressed stop acting
like you're going to lose something if
if if they have the privileges that you
have stop right it's enough for that
[ __ ] yeah and for republicans too it's
like if they you know if the gqp or
whatever you want to call them if they
actually gave people
fair equal rights to voting and and
having a say
they're afraid the fact that what's
going to end up happening is that the
popular thing that's going to be done is
or policies will be implemented are
democratic because they actually benefit
from the majority if not all people
because it's for their well-being it's
for the greater good for them but if
they you know suppress them and say well
we don't want all of them to vote
equally we want to we want to make sure
that only this group votes you know
that's the whole thing is like if they
are able to hold back a certain group
from having their say
then they're able to stay in control and
keep that generational kind of power in
play but if you know their greatest fear
is equal voting then they realize that
most people would probably end up voting
democratic because those policies are
the ones that actually
rebuild repair and
replenish
america right so so joe let me let's
talk about how how we
message our way because democrats aren't
the best at messaging and that's kind of
what you do on twitter is message and i
think you do a damn good job at it um
and i think i think that's why you have
over 200 000 people who follow you
because you are damn good at messaging
and
you know whether you give yourself
credit for that or not and i know i know
you have a a podcast thing coming up and
hopefully we'll have you back on once
you get that started we can help you
promote your your show
because that goes along with the
messaging as well me and gabe really
believe that the louder we yell and the
more we use comedy and satire the better
off it is but i don't want to end on the
note that that fascism because it is at
the front door it is knocking and it is
here it's not it's not a hyperbolic
thing we are in the throes of are we
going to be fascist state or not but to
the messaging part like
tell people
because i believe you can speak to this
more than because i think you see
yourself as a normal person that has
acquired this twitter account that you
would never dream of having in a
messaging platform that you never but
tell people what they can do tell them
how it matters how you message like
because i always say stay pissed go
[ __ ] vote because democrats are the
only ones that are going to deliver you
democracy because the republicans want
to destroy it so we have to have
strategic outrage to make sure we save
it so tell tell people what the you know
because it is knocking on our door and
we have to do something about it but how
is them tweeting how is them getting
messaging correct how is it effective
because i think it moves the needle i
definitely think it moves the needle i
think you can get people like i said
before like
it could be really really easy right now
it could have been easy for four years
to just sort of crawl up into a ball and
say i give up because
you know
it's it's it's it's hard and it's
relentless and it never stops and any
day
um where you're feeling like you can't
do it anymore you might need someone out
there who put something into the
universe that kind of peps you up and
refocuses you and re-energizes you
because at the end of the day we can't
we can't stop fighting um whatever that
means if it just means right now if it
means tweeting to encourage everybody
else around you not to give up and to
focus on what's going on to open their
eyes to what's going on um it helps
i think uh get people engaged and get
them
angry and get them motivated to vote as
you said because that's the number one
most important thing we just saw in the
2020 election
um 81 million people voted for joe biden
and and thank god
pulled us back from the edge of the
cliff um
i think that that's really important i
think it's also super important to hold
um
truth to power i think uh call out these
liars on their lies because what they're
doing right now but again with
legitimate political discourse comment
it's so i know it sounds overplayed to
say that these things are orwellian but
they are it's don't believe your eyes
like don't believe what you're actually
seeing and if they're able to dismantle
truth if they're able to tear down just
the basic premise of what is an actual
fact then they can rebuild anybody's
minds to believing whatever they want
them to believe and so we have to keep
standing up to that and if it's if it's
a lie or if it's an intentional um you
know mistruth or whatever i mean pompeo
is the king of [ __ ] that like oh that
don't get me started but we have to keep
calling them out because
this i don't know if it's going to
change their strategy but it's not
they're going to keep lying but at least
it maybe will keep other people engaged
to the point where they're like okay i'm
not going to give up here either
um and that's important so i don't know
for me
tweeting
is is important because it gets people
really fired up and refocused and
energized and we need to be prepared to
fight with everything that we have right
now that's how i feel about that i i'm
so excited that you came on and talked
about this because i think it's super
important that people understand that um
even if you know joe has a big account
and um but she struggled to get to a
thousand um and but her message is out
there now and your message can be out
there too don't give up and don't give
up on democracy because it is the actual
weapon that we're going to use to fight
fascism that ballot is the ammo that we
have to make sure to crush fascism so so
joe um i know you have a podcast that's
going to be coming up and i want to have
you back on when you when you launch um
because i want to talk to you more about
that when you when you get that figured
out because i'm i'm excited to to see
what you come up with here i tell
everyone tell everyone exactly where
they can find you um what what jojo's up
to and and how how they follow you and
all the all the places and also the one
thing i want them to know is exactly how
they get to these becky sue videos
because they are some of my favorite
so tell us where we find them so i'm on
twitter at jojo from jurors uh that's a
z at the end of jurors um
and i'm on instagram jojo. from jurors
because somebody out there has that
handle i don't know who but um and then
i'm on facebook as well
um and then my tick tock which my son
hates me staying but i have a tic tac
and that's uh
so that's that's where my becky sue
videos live and that's where they
originate i'm due for one soon um and
then i have a patreon which is jojo from
jurors
that's at patreon.com
and um yeah i've got some pretty cool
stuff coming up got a project i'm
working on with somebody i'm really
excited to work with that should be
coming soon
um
what else
yeah
that's oh i'm going to be doing a
newsletter for my patreon so that's
exciting and then my patreon also have
like q and a's and stuff like that on
zoom so that's fun if you want to talk
to me
um go go follow us
go follow jojo in all those spots go
check out our patreon and and and be and
follow her because the news will come
with this new podcast project that uh
that is happening super exciting um joe
thank you for coming on again
joe i appreciate i appreciate you
joining us it's it's so fun to have you
on and you have to come back
maybe we'll make this a regular thing
where you can come on and and give us uh
the lowdown on maybe a tweet that
happened or something that you got
trending um you know
jojo makes news or something like that
um
we can hash it out so thank you for
joining us everyone stay stay with us
we'll be right back right after this
break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back
on the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
headlines
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back
thanks for sticking with the interview
what a great interview
[Music]
i gotta gotta get it going here
dave's all over the place here whoa
yeah well you know what that was a great
interview
i really liked hanging out with joe that
was yeah it was great
uh everyone needs to go follow joe if
you're not following her already which
i'm sure
almost everyone out there listening
follows her but if you're not if you're
not going follow her on tick-tock to
watch these becky sue videos you have to
because the becky's two videos are like
they're so great and
we worked with joe um for becky sue for
wokesgiving and that was that was like
really fun to like go through the
writing process with becky sue even
right um that was really fun yeah
creators ourselves is funny right yeah i
mean like gaber
gave her a free reign on that when it
was like here's the topic that we want
to discuss
you figure it out and i'll
you know figure out what question or
reaction i need to be as uh
you know we should we should do the
whole idea that we had on the the
interview there where um becky sue goes
on joe rogan's show yeah um i think we
should do that that somehow play that in
where maybe maybe she appears on joe
rogan's show those two characters like
collide in that oh i could see that
world overlapping for sure yeah
absolutely absolutely and you know
mentioning while we're mentioning really
news now go follow that twitter account
at really news now hopefully we'll be
doing more and more videos this year as
the parody
um dies and the funeral happens and we
have to bury it we'll try to go over
there and bring it to like a level 30.
um you know because that's what you have
to do with parody and satire like we
said that you've never been like me and
you have talked about it just it just it
you can't [ __ ] get you can't make it
any worse like even the trump statement
today apparently is so bad it's not like
people aren't even posting it they're
like this isn't like this isn't even
good uh yeah people ask me if uh
like after joe biden was like no you
can't use executive privilege that's
just not gonna happen for these logs
and some people came to me and were like
so you got a statement and i was like
right so is there a mar-a-lago official
statement like uh yeah i know i thought
about it i was like oh man i don't know
maybe i could but i didn't have enough
time and by this point it's already out
the thing that has to happen is the
event has to happen
and then
it's either a release happens before
that
before his or
uh it's a follow-up to be like oh by the
way what i meant to say was you know
this wait i just thought of something do
you think do you think this whole true
social thing is a work around the gabe
statement where you pre-empt
like he's like look we gotta come up
with true social we're going to it's
going to be great we're going to charge
you 499.99
yeah
because what's going to happen is he
might not he might he might stop
releasing statements because he'll just
tweet on his and then they'll screenshot
so we're really going to have to do like
a screen grab thing where
i know
the other thing is i was looking at the
i was looking at uh these screenshots of
the app and
because i was gonna somebody did a side
by side but i was gonna find i was gonna
make it better side by side that had it
like is it like it's spot-on does the
exact same as twitter well
yeah i mean it looks it looks pretty
identical and so i look at and i'm like
oh well you know what they say
uh
you know what is it uh
imitation is the
the highest form of flattery right you
know and this is identical so uh but the
only difference is the blue check is red
yeah it's like a it's like a reddish
pink
but when i look at this
uh the screenshot
you know it shows
the account says truths
and then truths and and replies
and then media right so it's like
identical to be like are you truthing is
that what you're doing right so that's
what i was thinking about like during
the interview when when i was playing
the video i was thinking i was like so
you know you you said earlier like oh
well you know you're gonna i forgot what
the exact crazy yeah you're right so
you're gonna tweet right but it's like
are you gonna truth
right yeah right i don't know are you
like that's what i'm thinking i'm like
like that yeah you guys you got oh man
did you see that trump truth did like it
doesn't roll off right
as like as it should be
so i don't know it's it's gonna be um
the the the daniel dale
fact checks
that are going to ensue
uh hopefully in the near future because
i see that they might not even get the
app open he'll just keep tweeting and
don jr just keeps spreading around the
screenshot and hopefully there'll be
other screenshots that just start
circulating around and maybe
you know how would you verify how would
daniel dale verify
that a screenshot would be real or not
if he can't actually get on the app and
verified how is that even possible i
mean yeah it's throwing up
if that tree falls in the forest no
one's around to hear it doesn't make a
sound
you know
oh my god okay everyone join us tomorrow
at noon eastern 11 central um hopefully
tomorrow we're gonna have dakota adams
back on there's a lot of stuart rhodes
news happening apparently there's a
hearing today i don't know if it's
happened yet
i've been watching a few accounts to see
if this has been happening
there's been a few articles uh tasha
adams as you know his exchange ex-wife
she was on her show and so was dakota
his estranged son um we're gonna we're
gonna record a little bit with him um
this afternoon to get his response to
some of that news and then we'll
probably play that tomorrow sometime
during the show it won't be a full
interview we just want to get a
statement on some of the news that's
happening that's that's super important
um we want to bring dakota back on as
much as we possibly can as the stewart
rhodes and the oath keeper news starts
to evolve into this seditious conspiracy
in court um so because i think he can
speak a lot to and i think he's very
knowledgeable
on
the militia part of it and what the
mindset is of these people and how their
mindset kind of changed so that's
important so stick around tomorrow for
that noon eastern 11 central youtube
twitter twitch go to the merch store go
to gabe's merch store we need to get
those animations done i know emergency i
gotta work on that um call call the
graphics department and let them yeah
yeah i'll get it i'll get them online
after this yeah well okay good well you
know that that way we can put all the
maybe we can show pictures of our
t-shirts or something if you're watching
if you're listening go to
thetonymichaels.com gabe where do they
go for your your merch they go to
sanchez dot store.iamgabesanchez.com
fantastic so go to those two stores um
if you want to support the podcast it's
a great way to do it for me and gabe
until tomorrow
until tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking